We just do a quick sound check.
Uh,
Casey would you have for breakfast this morning?
Cheerio's obviously honey nut cheerios,
the breakfast of champions.
All right,
bear with me one sec.
I can run flat out start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already used Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works.
Taskrabbit uses it to tell the company story and there are many other names you
would recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and a fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business that's vim,
e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business Promo Code Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are just prodigies,
hedge fund managers,
celebrities like the Governor Arnold Schwartzenegger or say legendary music
producers like Rick Ruben,
anyone in between military,
artistic,
you name it.
There are patterns that you can tease out and it is my job to try to find the
routines,
the habits,
the favorite books,
the meals and the timing.
Everything that you can apply from their life to your own to develop your own
skills,
to develop your own version of success,
both in your personal and professional lives.
And this episode is no exception.
I had the chance to chat with Casey Neistat.
We've been trying to get together for a very long time.
Casey is a fascinating film maker.
He would also call himself a youtuber and if you look for his name on the
Interwebs,
Casey Neistat,N ,
He's also at Casey Neistat on Twitter.
You find headlines like the following from adweek health filmmaker Casey Neistat
gets away with murder.
That was the headline and talks about how he effectively took a budget than Nike
gave him and used it to travel around the world with his friend and then had
Nike thank him for it.
Another headline from Teen Welfare,
dad to youtube icon,
both accurate.
Next headline.
Casey Neistat can pretty much do anything that he wants to see.
You see the pattern here and uh,
it's,
it's a very fascinating story because Casey has done the opposite of what a lot
of people feel you should do.
In other words,
he was a very popular indie director,
had won all sorts of awards at Sundance Popular and HBO has a wall full of
awards and move to self publishing on the Internet instead.
Right now mo,
most people look at say going on youtube as a starting point to stair step to
more traditional media and distribution.
He did the opposite.
He's a high school dropout and uh,
we met through a very good friend of mine named [inaudible] at the Mit media lab
and we cover a lot.
We cover his history,
we cover overcoming adversity.
We talk about his decision to Vlog that has put out one video per day and how
that decision made his popularity explode.
He's a,
he's a quirky guy,
he's a,
he's very well known for running.
So we talking about the physical aspect of his life,
he still makes a lot of his own props and there are lots of questions I wanted
to ask.
For instance,
you know,
if you are able to charge five,
six figures,
maybe more for product placement and youtube videos,
why on earth would you start yet another company,
a startup,
a tech startup.
It's a fascinating guy.
I love his work and I hope you enjoy this conversation as much as I enjoyed it.
Say hello to Casey at Casey Neistat,
C a.
S e y.
N e.
I.
S.
T.
A.
And without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation with Casey Neistat.
Casey,
welcome to the show.
Great to be here.
I have had so many requests from my fans to connect with you.
And of course we have many mutual friends,
Ryan holiday,
a CEP Cam Var,
very old buddy of mine among others.
And I'm a fan of your work,
so thanks for making the time.
Yeah,
it's great to,
it's great to finally speak.
I feel like you and I've tried to actually connect physically on the phone.
Uh,
I think when there was a text back and forth at one point in time,
so it's nice to finally,
uh,
it's nice to finally hear your voice.
I think it's,
it's faded to happen,
you know,
things connect when they're intended to connect on some level.
And that having been said,
you are in New York City and just had,
it would seem like the,
uh,
the entire squad squadron of police cars from Nyp pull up outside your house.
This isn't like the professional or anything.
Is there any,
any,
any catastrophe pending outside of your
no.
And,
and I warned you of that before we started recording just to let you know that
when you hear sirens in the background or whatever it might be,
not to be alarmed,
but I think one of,
one of the biggest battles for me,
uh,
of being a filmmaker making movies in New York City for 15 years now has been
figuring out how to navigate the incessant noise pollution that is downtown
Manhattan.
And to paint a little picture for your audience,
my,
my office is on the second floor facing Broadway.
So that means is that the exact height of all the exhaust pipes that he's really
loud buses that drive by.
And I have single pane windows.
So,
um,
I will try my best.
But if you,
if you hear what sounds like some sort of battle taking place in the background,
know that everything's fine.
That's just New York City.
I remember very distinctly this one night when I was working on my TV show and
we had to do voiceovers,
we had to do pickup lines and we were filming,
I'm not going to name the hotel,
but,
uh,
in a hotel room in New York City that was on the third or fourth floor in a very
busy intersection.
And literally every time I got three quarters of the way through any line,
we tried this at two different times during the day.
We had to start over and over and over.
It was just the most maddening experience imaginable.
But,
um,
the,
uh,
how do you contend with that?
Actually,
we'll,
we'll start there because I remember this joke that someone told me about audio
and they said,
you know,
why does thunder come after lightening and it,
because even God has to wait for audio.
And is that a,
is that one of the biggest challenges of working in New York City?
Are there other challenges that people might not be aware of?
Um,
I mean I think that's probably the most like tactal that's,
that's probably easiest to point to,
but I'd say like,
to digress here,
it's,
it's more than just the battle that is recording audio for films that this is
noise pollution in New York City.
But my wife and I moved to,
to try back that we actually live on Broadway in New York City and the grumbling
of a garbage truck or a cement mixer or a bus,
I have become so sensitive to that.
I freak out when it goes by and my wife has to tell me to calm down.
And it's one of the biggest reasons why I want to leave the city knock or 15
years is it's just,
it's a noise that it's not just a noise like lightening or thunder or loud
music.
It's a noise that just kills all other noises.
So it's like this black cloud of sound that prevents any communication or
conversation or human interaction.
It just destroys everything.
Um,
and it wrecks my world and I take it so personally.
Uh,
and you've been in the city then for 15 years,
but you grew up in Connecticut,
is that right?
Yeah,
so I lived in,
I was born and raised in southeastern Connecticut and I always,
I always sort of preface that by saying I'm from the poor part of Connecticut.
I'm from the shitty part of Connecticut,
not Connecticut as always.
When people think Connecticut,
they think Greenwich and the fancy parts in Connecticut has kind of a,
another side to those tracks.
And that's where I'm,
and is it true that you were on welfare at one point?
Because I was,
I was going to bring that up later in the conversation,
but I've read that.
And is,
is that,
is that true?
When you dry it,
it,
uh,
Ryan and I have to have talked about your background and how fascinating it is,
but,
uh,
he,
he told me that you had dropped out of high school and then I had read that you
were on welfare,
but I was just hoping if you could provide some context around those kind of
early years.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
you know,
I had a,
I had a troublesome,
like adolescence,
one of four kids and my parents got a divorce when I was in,
I think a freshman in high school.
And I think it's always a real challenge for,
for any family.
But at that age,
I think it's probably the most,
you know,
I have a grown son now who's,
who's a senior in high school and the freshman in high school at 13 years old is
such a vulnerable age for young people.
Um,
and I didn't cope very well with the issues that were happening at home.
And I ran away from home and moved in with this girl and got her pregnant
because that's what teenagers do.
Um,
and you know,
I had a kid,
my son was born two weeks after my 17th birthday.
Um,
and you know,
I never,
I never went back home after running away from home at age 15.
I never went to my parents for money.
Um,
I just kind of,
when I say I left home,
I,
I proper laptop,
I never went back.
Um,
and yeah,
when,
when my kid was born,
we were on welfare,
we got free,
let me think,
what was it?
We got free mill and then there was something else.
It's like welfare is,
you get this,
you get this credit card that you can spend money on,
on anything.
Um,
and then you get free milk and maybe free diapers.
I don't really remember how it worked as long time ago,
but certainly it was very helpful at that time of my life.
And the,
how did the bridge from that point to film come about because,
and we'll talk about some,
some of your specific work,
but how did that develop the sort of interest in foray into filmmaking?
Uh,
you know,
I think that it's funny cause it,
Tim,
that question itself is something that I've only really been started to examine
in the last couple of years of my career.
Um,
as people ask me more and more and especially with the launch of my tech company
and looking back at it,
I think it's a pretty specific thing,
which is that you was one of four kids.
It was like the middle of sort of forgotten child,
not the youngest,
not the oldest,
not the girl,
but the other one that was me.
Um,
so I always was sort of the loudest to get the most attention because nobody
paid attention to me.
Um,
so with my psychiatrist says anyways and,
and I,
I think like when my older brother Van who I credit with getting me into
filmmaking when he showed me in,
in 2000 or 1999 and how the first Imac,
that big blue bubbly looking imac thing,
how you could edit video on that.
I just saw something that really captured my imagination.
And when,
uh,
he and I edited the very first thing I ever edited,
which is taking my,
at the time baby son to the zoo.
All of a sudden I saw this opportunity to take what was an idea or set of ideas
that really existed in my head and turn it into something tangible,
turning into something that I could then share with people and for someone who
had spent my whole life,
then I'll 18 years of at 19 years of it feel like I never had a voice all of a
sudden via filmmaking.
Um,
I sort of felt like I had a voice at a loudspeaker.
That makes perfect sense.
And from that,
from that feeling,
um,
let's,
let's flash forward for a second because I really want to introduce people to
some of your work if they haven't seen it before.
But could you talk about bike lanes or make it count?
Whichever came first.
Yeah,
bike lanes came first,
but,
um,
bike lanes is a really good example of that.
Bike lanes is probably,
there's only been a,
how do I preface this?
People ask,
like,
where do you come up with the ideas for your movie?
And I said,
I always say like,
whatever affects me,
whatever impacts and you,
whatever I care about is what I make your movie about.
And bike lanes is a movie I made in 2010.
I think maybe it's 2011 where in I was given a,
uh,
a summons from a police officer for riding my bike outside of the bike lanes,
which for starters it turns out is not an actual infraction.
Um,
but beyond that,
it really frustrated me because I wasn't breaking any laws and I felt that I was
doing something that was completely just,
um,
and I think what most people would have done is maybe gone to court and fought
that $50 summons and probably would have won and wasted a half of their day in
the process.
But I redirected my anger and I made a movie that really expressed my
frustration but did it in a somewhat sardonic way.
Um,
and that movie went tremendously viral online.
It was seen like 5 million times and it's the first day.
And this was before I had an audience on Youtube.
Um,
and at one point in time,
Mayor Bloomberg actually I actually had to respond to a question about the video
in a press conference.
Um,
so yeah,
that's a very,
that's a really literal example of me being a frustrated kid and wishing I had a
way for everyone to hear in a way to share my frustrations.
And that movie is very much so a,
a compartmentalization at that exact emotion.
And then outcome
knowing in concrete terms.
Can you give people sort of a visual though for what you,
you ended up doing in that film?
Yes.
It's very buster,
very buster Keaton in Hawaii.
I think cops argument was predicated on this idea that the bike lanes are there
to keep you safe.
The bike lanes are for cyclists.
I was writing outside of the bike lanes,
therefore I was unsafe and should be summoned,
uh,
are given a sentence.
Um,
so I made a movie where it just sort of start from the beginning where I say the
cops and had to stay in the bike lane no matter what.
And no matter what is,
is underscored and I proceed to ride my bike around New York City into
everything that is in the bike lanes,
preventing people from actually cycling safely within the lanes themselves.
Um,
and that sort of crescendo is when I,
when I crashed into a police car that was parked in the middle of a bite.
Right.
So with something like that,
now the bike lanes taking this frustration or dissatisfaction and scratching
your own itch,
which segues nicely into tech and we'll,
we'll get to that also.
I mean all,
almost all of the best founders I know are scratching their own itch when they
create a product or a service.
Uh,
I mean,
for instance,
with the,
looking at the,
the iPod batteries and whatnot.
Have you had,
have you had a case where you vented frustration in a public way that you
regretted after the fact or wished you'd handled differently?
Regrets,
a strong word,
but one that I look back on and sort of shake my head was,
um,
as very young,
when was this?
I'm trying to come up with a year for you,
Tim.
And I don't know,
but I was probably 22 or something like that and I was,
it was a real,
I was a nobody then nobody knew who I was and I just made a movie with my
brother about bicycle captain New York City and they invited us on morning,
local morning news to talk about bike that then they wanted us to recreate a
bike being stolen.
Um,
and we showed up there and this woman who was the,
uh,
the host of the morning,
the morning news was so rude to us cause we were just kids or two kids show up
early in the morning.
She was so rude and so mean to us.
And then she swore at her intern in front of us and we're just like,
my God,
this is a woman.
Who does she think she is.
So we,
we kind of pranked her on air.
And my brother pretended to cut,
cut me when he was releasing the bike.
And I,
this was,
I want to say like maybe when youtube had just come out,
this is like,
so it hadn't been 2005,
2006 and that scene when crazy,
crazy,
crazy viral.
Um,
and it's basically this woman talking to camera about what's taking place and
here they are demonstrating a bike lock and then all of a sudden I start
screaming and dropped to the ground and squeeze Kevin.
It's all over myself.
And at no point in time did anyone,
especially the woman think that it was real.
I'm not a very good actor.
Um,
I had ketchup packets all over me and my brother was like shaking his head.
but her response is what got people so excited?
Cause she freaked out a few very quickly turned into that Werewolf that was
wearing it in turns earlier in the day.
And in any event,
um,
it became this huge story.
It was all over the New York Post and it was like,
uh,
you know,
they,
they vilified her and it was whatever it was,
what it was.
But looking back at it like I'm not a huge fan of pranks.
I'm not a huge fan at a laugh that's at someone else's expense.
And I think so much of the response to that was,
was out of context.
Like the world didn't that this,
that were,
that I was doing this because this one was mean to me.
The world disarmed me being kind of like a,
a prankster and that's an image that I don't like to project.
So the,
the facts that is ms contextualized I think is sort of a silly,
uh,
was a silly thing.
That was the the bike thief.
Yeah.
Not,
and not the video itself cause this,
this little prank that we pulled on there,
I think that it was,
it sort of lacked the,
it lacked the societal or cultural relevance of maybe some of my other a yippee
movies that that definitely had a purpose.
This was much more of just a,
just being a jerk prankster trying to go,
which is definitely not how I described anything else that I've ever done in the
tenure of my career.
When when someone asks you,
what do you do these days,
how do you answer that?
I'm sure it depends on the context,
but in general,
how do you respond to that question?
Oh,
I'm a youtuber.
Got It.
You know,
it used to say,
uh,
in my Twitter bio that Casey Neistat,
creator of the HBO series,
at one point in time I said that I like a award winning film maker.
I don't think I gave myself that title,
but others that's not an inaccurate title.
Um,
and now and I just take a big step back and I say,
what am I,
how do I want to be identified?
Um,
I think being a youtuber or being sort of being like every other kid on youtube
is,
is maybe the most flattering,
a flattering context for me to live in.
Um,
I like tech entrepreneur,
but it's a such a pretentious kind of stupid title that if there were,
if there were an easier way to say that,
if there were a lesson knowing where to say Tech Entrepreneur,
I would say that that's it because 90% of my time is my technology company and
10% is creating youtube videos,
but 90% of my efforts and the tech company are internal facing and not external
facing and 100% of what I do on Youtube,
um,
go straight out to the world.
So for all those reasons I identify most as a youtuber.
And uh,
let's,
let's talk about one of your most,
if not the most,
correct me if I'm wrong,
popular video on your Youtube Channel,
which is make it count.
Is that still the most popular
think?
So,
I don't know.
The one I released,
uh,
when I released 38 minutes ago,
I hope gets more,
more views than that.
Um,
yeah.
And make it count is a really,
is a really interesting case study.
10 because that was such an inflection point in my career as a filmmaker
who historically I had directed advertisements as a main primary means of
income,
um,
which is a really convoluted,
unnecessarily complicated,
somewhat ridiculous process.
We're just a tremendous amount of money is wasted.
And at the end of the day,
you turn out something that is sort of creativity by committee,
which is mushy,
invisible and just no one cares about.
And that's how I described 99% of all advertising that's done.
Um,
and after Mayfield show,
when I was trying to figure out what to do
with my career,
I went to the production company that represented me,
the company that brought me my advertising gigs.
And I said,
all I want to do is make awesome videos,
put them on the Internet and then find companies that'll give me money to make
awesome videos like my other videos,
but I'll do it for them.
And my production company shook their head at me and they said,
good luck.
It will never work like that.
So I immediately stopped working with them and I went on my own.
I kind of went rogue and somewhere in there,
Nike came to me in and I did this tiny project with them,
which led to a larger project,
which was a three,
a three movie at three Internet movie deal.
Um,
and the first two movies were right down the line.
They were,
there were what you'd expect.
I had big,
big,
huge,
you know,
a hundred million dollar athletes.
And then there were very well received.
I loved making them,
but when it came time to make the third movie,
I was really burnt out from,
from the process.
And at the Ninth Hour I called my editor up and I said,
hey,
let's not make this advertisement.
Let's not make this movie.
And said,
let's do something I've always wanted to do,
which is let's just say the entire production budget and travel the world,
um,
until we run out of money and we'll record that and we'll make some sort of
movie about that.
And he said,
you're crazy.
But sure.
It wasn't his ass.
It was mine.
And that's,
that's exactly what we did and make it count,
became this video about running around the world and sort of chasing after what
matters to you.
And that was the point.
That was the message of the campaign was to make it count,
was to make every moment in life counts.
So there was something sort of poetic about the fact that by us going rogue and
taking this budget and doing something we weren't supposed to do,
but that's something that narrative was so perfectly in line with their
messaging that in the end we had something that they were tremendously excited
about.
And that was an,
I'm not sure any Morton because I haven't checked on Youtube.
Um,
but that was Nike's most watched video on,
on the Internet for a number of years.
And everyone's really excited about the way that it turned out.
What did the phrasing,
what was your phrasing and the first phone call or email when you gave Nike the
heads up on what you'd actually done?
Sure.
So a little context for your,
for your listeners out there.
The,
the video literally opens with scrolling text that says,
Nike gave me a budget to make them a commercial.
Instead I blew the budget travelling the world.
Um,
and that's literally what happened.
So,
so some details around that to color in what happens specifically?
It was like,
firstly,
this was the smallest budget of all three budgets for all three videos.
So this is the kind of budget that I would say would be equivalent to what Nike
typically spends on craft services,
what they typically spend on snacks for one of their huge music for one of their
huge advertisements.
So there wasn't that much accountability on of that.
They
knew me,
they trusted me,
and they weren't working with me because they thought I could make them a
perfect TV commercial.
They were working with me because they wanted something different.
So I called them before,
before I did this,
before it took off and I said,
look,
I'm not going to do the treatment,
um,
treatments,
like a script.
I'm not going to follow this.
I'm gonna do something different.
And they said,
okay,
what are you going to do?
And I said,
I don't know,
but I'm going to travel and it's going to be great.
And they just said like,
it was one executive in particular as got into Alex Lopez.
He's still at Nike and he's an incredible creative genius.
And he was like,
Casey,
just don't screw me over here.
I said,
I was like,
Alex,
no promises,
but we're going to go.
Um,
and then we were sort of like radio blackout for the next,
for the next 10 days.
You know,
we,
how we did that movie and you know,
we hit like whatever 15 countries and in nine days.
But we had a girl here in New York City and she was working pretty much around
the clock.
And if you get an email from me from whatever Internet cafe I was in saying we
want to go here next,
um,
and then she would figure out how to make it happen until the money dried up.
And when you were doing that,
I mean,
you've,
you've done a fair amount of traveling.
I mean did,
did you,
do you have any particular routines or tricks for maintaining sanity or at least
minimizing a completely burning yourself out when following that type of
schedule?
Um,
well firstly,
that type of schedule is a unique type of schedule that is,
that is like defcon one total chaos schedule that's completely unsustainable,
unrealistic.
And that I would advise no human being on earth to ever attempt that.
I like that one detail to that.
I did it with my best friend Max and we went,
it wasn't till our sixth night of travel that we slept horizontally and that's
not like you were keeping track.
So we were sleeping upright.
Coach seats either on airplanes are on buses,
like going from,
from Zambia to to Kenya.
Like we just,
we never ever laid down.
And I remember our,
our feet were so swelled were so swollen that we couldn't get them into our
shoes.
We just had these big fat,
swollen feet.
Um,
so I recommend it for no one.
Uh,
that said,
I still travel quite a bit.
Um,
and I consider myself like a real expert when it comes to traveling.
10 you're,
you're someone who has probably define what it means to hack life better than
anyone else.
When it comes to traveling though,
I think that,
uh,
I've got a really good grip on where all the loopholes and shortcuts are to
really like remove the hate that is a commercial aviation.
Could you give a,
could you give people a taste?
Well sure.
And it,
it's funny cause you tweeted earlier and I know you have a video I saw,
I saw some fans link back to it.
So I'd love for you to give a little bit of color on that.
You tweeted earlier today,
what did I ask Casey and our,
our interview
today and somebody tweeted back,
uh,
some,
something negative about the movie I made about how to get free upgrades or do
my investors get angry because I only fly first class.
And the truth is if you fly enough,
you can really,
really crack the whole system.
That is,
that is flying commercial.
That said,
it's very important to say this loud and clear.
If you don't fly a ton,
if you don't,
if you don't spend at least 200,000 miles in the air a year,
which is that which is about six times around the earth,
if you don't do that,
none of these tricks work.
These only work if you fly a lot,
but if you fly a lot and you fly with one airline and you really climbed the top
of the heap,
which is airline status and you build a relationship,
you can almost always ensure that you will get special treatment and after
flying a lot of kind of makes sense.
Like if you're the airline,
why should you cater to a mass audience that just goes on Kayak in search of the
cheapest flights and then jumps on a plane?
There's no loyalty there.
There's nothing there that incentivizes someone to fly with you.
But someone like me who spends ungodly amounts of money flying and traveling
every year,
of course,
of course I want to court my influence and my loyalty and that courtship is
something that you can exploit to your own benefit.
And I guess that's how I describe what it means to hack hack commercial.
Do you,
uh,
if,
if you traveling and trying to travel light,
but you're going to be recording video,
what is your Goto g,
what is your Goto kit look like?
What type of gear?
Well,
I always,
I always travel light.
It doesn't matter whether I'm going somewhere for an overnight,
you're going somewhere for a month and a half.
I always have the same setup,
which is one small as big as it can possibly be while still be a carry on,
rolling suitcase.
And then my backpack and all of my camera years in my backpack and my laptop and
all my,
everything else is in the rolling suitcase.
But literally I can't fit a pair of socks into my backpack,
so I always have to have the second bag with the miscellaneous is in clothing in
it.
Um,
but camera gear's pretty cut and dry eye.
I always have a point and shoot and then I always have an SLR.
What type of point and shoot and Slr do you do you've currently favor?
Well,
I,
this is not by any means an endorsement because I can talk ad nauseum about why
this hardware is absolutely terrible and everything's wrong.
Everything that's wrong with it.
Um,
but it's my current favorite.
So again,
this is not an endorsement of any capacity,
but I currently use the Canon 70 d as my main shooter,
including all my blogs.
And I do that because it's the only one that has,
it has the best auto focus technology of any SLR in the market.
Uh,
and when you're shooting with one hand,
you can't be pulling focus.
So that's why I use that.
And then my,
my latest point and shoot is the Sony rx 100,
which has been great.
Uh,
but there are some reliability
issues there,
which is exactly what I expect from Sony is reliability issues.
So what is still far more affection?
What is your,
what is your postproduction look like?
What are you using to,
what are the tools that you use for editing and post?
So I just use final cut 10,
which is really terrible software.
It's just not great.
It's there.
They're very real reliability concerns around it and it almost feels like it's
been handicapped by apple to appeal more to them the consumer and prose humor
than the professional market,
which is a antithetical to final cut seven and every previous iteration,
which was absolutely professional editing software.
Um,
I think they make this for,
for people that don't consider themselves pro one a lot of options.
So there's some benefits to that and some distractions to that.
Uh,
and I feel like I've sort of maxed out what the,
what the software is capable of.
Um,
and now I'm really starting to feel the fact that it's not,
uh,
it's not as capable as,
as other professional grade editing software.
Is there a,
is there any other software that you use in addition to,
uh,
in addition to that?
Not really.
Um,
you know,
I,
I'm all about speed and efficiency.
I upload every single day.
Um,
so with that,
you,
you lack the opportunity to spend a tremendous amount of time,
color grading or bringing into aftereffects to clean up or do the kinds of
things that technologies and software enabled us to do.
Um,
I have much less of an appreciation for what technology can bring my work and
much more of an appreciation for the craft of storytelling and in communicating
ideas and sharing messages,
which does not necessitate
the kinds of things that technology enables you to do today.
So looking at,
say other people taking a stab at Youtube,
what,
what are the biggest wastes of time generally speaking in your mind?
Or how,
how do novices waste the most time,
whether it's in the filming stage or an in post or otherwise?
I mean,
I,
I think it's much,
it's less technical than anything else.
I think that the biggest waste of energy and resources on,
uh,
on youtube as you see youtube creators trying to copy and be exactly like
someone else.
Um,
and the only thing that succeeds on youtube are people that are thinking outside
the box doing new things.
Uh,
and I can talk about that.
you know,
until,
uh,
until the cows come home because it's something I believe in so profoundly.
But,
you know,
youtube is built on originality and built on unfounded genres and styles of
content creation.
Um,
you know,
I think it's 2011.
Youtube spent $200 million,
uh,
sorry for that.
But they said they spent $200 million on,
um,
giving these huge budgets and known production
entities that is like the MTVs of the world.
And like Lacma for example,
and all these big entities,
200 million bucks,
they'd start youtube channels.
So original high quality content would be made just for youtube and every one of
them failed.
And at the same time that they were failing as $200 million,
we're evaporating all of these individuals,
all these young people creating content that fit into,
you know,
categories came up on youtube and a huge way.
And now it's those creators,
those original creators that are defining what youtube is,
and they're defining it in a way that does not exist inside any of the norms of
filmmaking.
In fact,
almost without exception,
most of the successful content creators on youtube don't come from a filmmaking
background,
but instead they've sort of,
uh,
they've,
they've like metastasize what is,
uh,
capability elsewhere,
like a,
an understanding elsewhere.
And they've turned that into success on Youtube.
Tyler Oakley was big on Tumbler,
use a big blogger and he turned that into being a vlogger.
And now he has,
he's is tremendously influential,
essentially talk show hosts,
which is,
which is what he does via youtube.
And what I'll,
I'll tell you how I first came in contact with your work,
which was,
I was having a conversation with a friend of mine named Jason Harris,
who works at a company called mechanism.
They do a lot of work with youtube offers and uh,
he's a very,
very smart guy.
And I was lamenting the fact that I felt like,
uh,
the ship had sailed on Youtube for me and that it was,
it was not the best fit because I couldn't find,
it was hard for me to find popular youtube who were not appealing primarily to
say like the 12 to 15 year old demographic with like super fast cuts,
um,
and with a very,
very particular style.
And I was pointed to your work because a number of folks,
including Jason said it was very smart and probably hit a similar demographic,
not so that I could copy it,
but the,
so I could look at it as a potential role model.
So for,
for,
for someone,
let's say in my shoes where I'm comfortable with text,
I'm comfortable with audio,
haven't done as much video,
all that.
Although I've dabbled in television,
I,
I am fascinated by the allure and promise and direct connection that youtube
offers.
How would you suggest someone like me gets started,
um,
on Youtube?
Would it be with a daily Vlog?
Would it be with something else?
How should I kind of get my feet wet and start getting enthusiastic about it?
You know,
I often get asked about what is the best way to achieve success on Youtube.
And the truth is if there were any one defined path,
if there were anything that was sort of a quantifiable or anything that could be
written out,
I think a lot of people would,
would follow that trajectory.
The reality is pretty far from that though.
There are,
I don't know what the exact number is,
but I think it's 1.1 billion different channels on youtube and there are 400
hours of content uploaded every minute of every day to youtube.
So like the vastness,
the depth that is the ocean of Youtube is,
is this huge abyss.
It's very hard to stand out.
Um,
and the only thing that I can say,
the only advice I ever give is,
is don't think,
um,
consideration will not yield success on Youtube.
I think it's purely based around action.
Um,
some other things that I,
I put is like quantity matters.
It's not just the quality of the work.
Um,
but it's also the quantity of the work.
People look to youtube not to find great wellmade films.
They look there for relationships.
Um,
I think that's why.
Yeah,
I think that's why when you look at like,
I don't know,
who can I pick on?
Look at Vanity Fair.
Vanity Fair's turning out this incredibly high production star studded content.
Nobody's watching and nobody gives a shit.
And that's not why people watch youtube.
There's no relationship there.
The reason why I'm psyched to be considered and identified as a youtube or
versus a filmmakers is youtube.
Unlike film making is not a one way street.
It's this reciprocal symbiotic relationship that,
that your content has with,
with a very specific audience and then that that audience has with your content.
So to succeed within there as is very challenging.
And I think the only way to do it is to find your own path.
The only way to find that path is to act is to start going.
And what,
what,
uh,
let me dig into that because I,
I like this thread,
uh,
and I'll just draw a parallel in writing.
So I remember at one point,
uh,
I was talking to Po Bronson,
a writer I admire and I asked him what he does when he feels blocked and he
said,
write about what you're right about,
what angers you,
like write about what makes you upset.
And thought that was very interesting advice.
But that was a very proved to be very helpful and has been helpful for me when I
feel like I'm having trouble getting started.
Um,
do you have any suggestions?
I'm happy to act and I think a lot of people listening would be as well,
but how do they,
what might be some angles or questions or ways they can get started,
forget about success just to start getting content out there.
Um,
sure.
Well,
I think that what you team uniquely possesses and its audience over any other,
any other distribution outlet is that the audience is so fine tuned to bullshit.
They're both fit detectors are so highly refined that even the slightest amount
of bullshit will set off their alarm and then you will be rejected.
The audience,
the community will reject you immediately.
So a great place to start is one of honesty,
um,
one of frankness.
Um,
and that sounds,
uh,
like hyperbolic or wish you off you,
but the truth is being yourself on camera as an incredibly difficult thing to
do.
Uh,
it's why the David Letterman's in the Jimmy Fallon's of the world are so
brilliant is because when you're watching Jimmy Kimmel on TV,
you really believe that that's who this guy is.
And when you see someone who's uncomfortable in front of the camera,
which is the vast majority of us,
it reeks of something else,
which maybe it's something that's contrived or something that's forced or
something that's fake.
So I always say start from a place of honesty and that's where the quantity
comes into play is because the more you're doing something,
the more comfortable you become with it.
Um,
so I think the combination of those two,
if you throw in a little bit of passion,
what truly motivates you,
what are you truly interested in?
I think you can find it really,
uh,
an actionable recipe for,
for starting or building a foundation on Youtube.
So
it's,
um,
it seems like,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
but that you putting out one video per day,
that decision is made,
your popularity really explode.
Um,
so I'd be,
I'd be curious to know why you think that has worked or why that has happened.
And then a question from a fan that came up was you said no to logging before
because he felt like it could make things feel contrived.
How do you feel about this now?
Um,
well those are,
those are two questions.
So let me tackle the first one,
which is about popularity and youtube.
You know,
the reason why I started daily blogging was because I have to unpack this a
little bit,
but when I started my technology company,
which is the social product,
which is,
it's a social network,
I always knew that I would need to lean on my own social reach and my own
influence to build a core use of core base of users for my product.
Um,
and then as I began and as my tech company in the construction of it,
really began by social reach,
started to atrophy because I wasn't creating content because I had run a
company.
Um,
so I'm really trying to examine how can I address both of these issues,
which is promote my own social influence.
So like we'll help my company.
Um,
I just made a decision and I'm on my birthday this year,
my 34th birthday that I'm going to start daily blogging.
And coincidentally,
I was like on this beautiful,
lovely trip with my family and an exciting location and the Caribbean and um,
and I had a lot of material those first four days and a lot of beautiful
material to show off a.
And that's what I did.
And when I got home,
uh,
the fourth lot of the fifth long ever made,
it's like me returning to work and I say to the camera like,
I don't know how sustainable this is because I live a fairly ordinary life where
I show up at work yet at eight or nine in the morning,
I leave work at seven at night,
I go home to my family and I go to bed.
There's not much in there that warrants blogging every single day.
Um,
and the reason why I bring that specific up,
Tim,
is because that dovetails with your next question,
which is I used to reject blogging because it was a little bit of,
is the wagging the tail or is the tail wagging the dog in that I don't want to
be living my life.
So it's interesting for my blog and the reason why those two points dovetails so
nicely.
It's because when I said that on the blog when I said,
I don't know how to make this interesting,
now that I'm back at my daily life,
I understood blogging as a visual public diary of one's life and I think that's
where I was wrong.
Um,
and what this thing that I call a blog and I embrace that title and it's a blog.
What it's become is instead of a daily show for me,
and that feels sometimes like,
like the blog I posted yesterday for example,
is very much so a diary because my wife and I and my daughter going on this
crazy trip out to queens to try to buy some funny clothes for a wedding that
we're going to in a few months.
It was very much so a diary.
But then you look at some of my other blogs,
which are just me sitting in front of a camera talking to,
talking to my audience about why I'm so passionate about filmmaking or,
or,
or something much more personal.
And it feels instead of a Vlog,
it feels much more like a confessional.
And some of my vlogs are examining technical things like my car,
my electric skateboard.
I've got an entire blogs dedicated to how this thing works.
And some of them were up building things and some of them are about how I
structure my daily life.
So really I just post every 24 hours and I call it a blog because that's the
easiest thing for me to call it,
that the people understand.
But the truth is it's not a diary of my life.
Instead it's this,
it's this outlet for whatever it is that interests me.
So I hope that answers the question from the fan.
It's that I understood when I said that comment about blogging,
I understood blogging to be one thing.
And then in practice,
and this is where this is,
this really reinforces that idea that I said about action is so important in
practice.
It really manifested as something wildly different from what I originally
understood it to be.
And in your,
in your daily practice,
your daily routine.
Um,
I've read that you might take,
say up to eight hours to edit one of your videos.
I don't know if that's true.
We can get a comment on that.
But how much time do you spend interacting with fans or viewers on Youtube,
Twitter,
all these different social platforms on a,
on a,
on an average daily basis?
I mean,
in aggregate I would say it's less than,
less than an hour.
Um,
I try my best,
but it's very hard.
Usually I check into my,
my daily upload about an hour after it's been posted.
I see who,
who's commenting on what they're saying,
and I jump in and try to reply to as many as I possibly can.
Um,
on Twitter,
you know,
you're,
you're pretty great on Twitter,
Tim.
I've been following you forever,
but you know,
you respond when you can have got a minute of downtime.
No one's looking,
you're sitting in a car,
you're waiting for something and you just jump on Twitter and you reply to a few
tweets.
Um,
but I would say there's nothing more defined than that for me.
and I,
I'd love to change that.
I'd love to figure out a way to have it be much more inclusive of my audience.
But regrettably,
time is fungible and to dedicate more time than I do currently to my audience
would need to take it away from somewhere else and I'm just not in a position to
do that.
What a,
and I do the same thing by the way.
I mean,
when I post a blog post,
typically I'll post at night so I can catch any errors that fans will point out
immediately.
So I'll try to hit,
say the UK or New Zealand and then answer questions the following morning,
uh,
or along those lines.
And it's something that you just have to batch,
but,
uh,
what was your first paid Gig,
related to film?
Or when did you realize that you could actually give this anonymous the
profession?
Awesome question.
Um,
the first day Gig I ever had was,
uh,
to make,
happy birthday video for this guy named Tom Tom's husband,
um,
was getting,
was he's turning 50 years old in Tom contacted my brother and I,
and he said,
Hey,
I've seen some of your little art movies,
um,
in the art world floating around the art world.
This is like 2001,
2002 rather.
And he was like,
I'd love to hire you to make a movie for my husband,
uh,
and for my husband's birthday.
And we're like,
okay,
great.
And he's like,
just let me know what it costs.
And all I knew at the time was that he was like a rich guy.
So like we debated for days,
like,
what do we charge this guy?
And we came back with what we saw was the most like ambitious number we could
possibly go to him with,
which is like,
we asked for $5,000.
And the truth is we were,
were willing and ready to do it for $100.
We knew he was a rich guy and we knew that he liked us and we knew that he'd
bought really fancy art.
So maybe just maybe we get away with it.
He didn't bat an eye at it.
He said,
no problem.
And then he said,
here are a list of people I'd love for you to interview about my husband.
And it was like President Clinton,
Senator Hillary Clinton,
like all the members of their cabinet,
like all of these triple a rockstar politicians.
And we were just like,
holy smokes,
who is this guy?
Um,
and it was,
it was Fred Hochberg who is currently the chairman of the import export bank and
his husband is a guy named Tom [inaudible] and Tom is currently the chairman of
the Fulbright Commission.
Um,
so there are two,
probably the biggest power couple,
one of the biggest power couples out there.
Um,
and there are two lovely guys who to this day I'm very,
very close friends with and we got our 5,000 bucks for that Gig.
And it was,
it was a huge deal.
That's amazing.
Did they just email you through the contact email and your website or how did
that connection happen?
Wow,
there's no website back then.
Back then,
back then I was working for $10 an hour as like an artist's assistant.
And in the interim I was making,
my brother Van and I were making these little movies in my apartment that we
would post on literally like apple I disc and we email around the link so people
could download the.mov files and watch them in somehow.
One of the artists we knew or something like that was like,
oh,
you gotta check out these two young maniacs that I've met who make these crazy
little videos.
And he saw it and he was like,
I don't want a boring video for Freddy's birthday.
I want something that like,
it's going to keep people laughing.
And he gave us this crazy,
this,
he gave us this assignment.
We came back with something absolutely crazy that involve like,
um,
that involved,
you know,
when we met with Hillary,
or sorry,
Bill Clinton,
they had a prepared statement on his teleprompter and when the secret service
left the room to go get the president,
I deleted all the information off the teleprompter.
And while the president is sitting there and his seat waiting for the
teleprompter,
I just remember him being like,
Nancy,
what's going on here?
I rushed over to him with my hands down so I didn't get tackled by security and
I was like,
hello,
Mr President,
my name's Casey.
I'm here to do this interview for you,
for Fred Hochberg.
Here's an idea I had.
And he started laughing.
He was like,
boys,
I love it.
And we hit record and we had the nugget recorded before they got the
teleprompter.
He was out of the room.
And when he said the joke that we had him say in front of the 500 people at Le
Cirque where we showed the movie for Fred's birthday,
it brought down the house.
That's a ballsy move.
But I mean,
I shouldn't be surprised.
You're pretty ballsy bald guy to start with.
I mean,
back then it was like definitely a nothing to lose kind of situation.
We were absolutely,
nobody's is getting paid $10 an hour for,
I couldn't afford food back then.
That's not,
that's not,
that's not hyperbole.
That is fact.
Now what,
when you,
um,
well let me,
let me take a step back with,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind and why?
That's a tough question.
Um,
my grandmother,
uh,
my grandmother is probably the most successful.
She passed away two years,
three years,
four years.
We've got stopped keeping track.
She passed away at age 92 and she is like,
she's my hero.
She's my muse.
She's my everything.
And the reason why is she started tap dancing when she was six years old.
She's a little fat girl and her parents made her do something to lose,
lose the weight.
So she started tap dancing and she loved it and she fell in love with something
at age six and she didn't stop tap in St until the day before.
She died at age 92.
She died on a Monday morning at age 92 and the first thing we had to do after
she died was call her 100 students to say she wasn't going to make class that
day.
Wow.
Um,
and for me it's just like,
I mean she's never rich.
Uh,
she actually never had a whole lot of money.
She's a tap dance instructor,
but she dedicated all the proceeds from her tap recitals to the American cancer
society to raise money to,
to beat cancer because cancer took her father.
Um,
so she's,
she's a total hero and a philanthropist despite not having the means.
And then on top of that is just like what,
what is the ultimate quantification of success?
For me,
it's not how much time you spend doing what you love,
it's how much time you spend or how little time you spend doing what you hate.
And this woman spent all day,
everyday doing what she loved all day.
If he spent almost no time doing the things she didn't want to do.
Um,
she just did,
which was she loved the most in life,
which is dancing.
And she did that with dancing was her life.
You'd wake up in the morning,
she was dancing and go to bed at night.
She's watching Fred Astaire and TV.
Um,
and that was her,
you know,
that was 86 years of her 92 years of existence.
She spent doing nothing but exactly what she loved.
And I just can't think of a higher benchmark of success than that.
So how,
how has that impacted you on a daily basis?
And I'll just,
I'll rephrase that.
When you wake up in the morning and you don't feel like putting out the video,
right,
do you have those days?
And if so,
what do you do in those circumstances?
What do you say to yourself?
Well,
I always want to put out the video.
I don't always want to make the video,
so like give a little structure to that.
My Day looks like is,
um,
I wake up at four 30 in the morning is when my alarm goes off.
This is seven days a week and I edit,
I finished my edit from the night before the edit gets done and usually between
six 30 and seven from seven to seven 45,
it's processing,
uploading,
um,
designing in,
in color,
correcting everything,
the thumbnail that goes on youtube,
preparing the posts.
So it's up,
it's live,
it's rendered,
it's fully processed and it goes live at exactly 8:00 AM that's seven days a
week.
Immediately after 8:00 AM I,
I work out,
which usually involves running,
um,
you know,
whenever I run eight to 12 miles or going to the gym and then I'm in my office
like nine 30 ish.
Um,
I live across the street from my,
from my office,
so it's a pretty narrow commute.
And then I work in my office all day long.
Are you usually try to get out of here by six 30 race home,
give the baby a bath,
um,
and then hanging out in their wife for an hour and a half.
She goes to bed at like nine and then I sit down to edit until I pass out in my
computer till one in the morning.
I sleep usually on the couch until four 30,
which is like,
you know,
three,
four hours later I wake up and I start over.
And that is seven days a week for me.
Um,
sometimes on the weekend I spend less time in the office,
but that's every day.
That's a brutal tough.
It's tough.
So have you always needed very little sleep?
Yeah,
I've always,
I've never ever been a fan of sleep.
I hate sleep.
Sleeping,
eating are like my two least favorite things to do and I'm frustrated everyday
when I get tired and I'm frustrated when I get hungry.
I can help you with the ladder.
Maybe not the tire,
but the uh,
been doing all sorts of fascinating experiments.
What time do you eat breakfast and what do you eat for breakfast?
I mean,
I usually don't,
uh,
I only,
like I said,
honey nut cheerios is when you asked me earlier during our audio,
during the sound check,
right?
Because,
whichever,
I have no idea who,
but some,
one of our team members have a tech company is a big fan of them.
So there's always hunting that chairs in milk in my,
in my,
my office.
So when I hear somebody else spooned clanking the porcelain,
I'm like,
Ooh,
cheerio's and I get up,
but just cause that's sugar and that's delicious.
Um,
but no,
I don't,
I don't know that I am a big breakfast eater.
I usually just wait until I get really hungry and then I eat until the hunger
stops.
And,
and then I repeat that
seems seems like the most natural way to go as opposed to eating by the clock.
You know,
I just have to mention honey nut cheerios.
I had breakfast with Larry King for the first time,
uh,
not long ago.
And we met at a sort of a Jewish bagel shop and he goes there every morning and
then eats honey nut cheerios so they have to keep it stocked at this place for
him.
I just thought that was one of the most unusual things I'd ever seen.
But it seems like a number of top performers eat honey nut cheerios for
breakfast.
So maybe there's something there.
Uh,
when that,
speaking of Larry King,
I've always kind of idolized him for his ability to get people to open up.
Uh,
do you,
you've met so many people,
so many successful people over the years in different professions,
uh,
who has made you feel starstruck
and y
Ou starstruck?
God,
that is a tricky one.
Uh,
it's funny cause you know,
I'd go to like a lot of big celebrity of events and it never really hits me with
the kinds of people that you would think that it would hit me with.
Um,
I'm trying to think.
Like I met Jack Welsh once in the street,
right.
And for whatever reason I was starstruck by him.
I was so excited to meet him.
Um,
but honestly,
I don't know.
I,
I really just starstruck is something that,
that that's an experience.
I don't know.
Super well.
And I guess the reason why it's just like I have about as much appreciation and
understanding of that as I do when people get excited to meet me.
And I say that right now,
looking out the,
I have a monitor in my office that camera films just outside the sidewalk and I
can count one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11,
12,
13,
14 kids standing outside of my office right now,
rating,
waiting to see me.
That's every day.
Uh,
it's never stopped and I haven't got as much understanding or ability to
understand,
empathize with those kids.
I said,
my office is,
I do get the idea of getting starstruck.
Um,
so why Jack?
Why Jack Welch?
I had no idea and they say just finished one of his books,
but,
um,
and I had all these ideas in my head that he had planted there and that's
something flattering.
But no,
I,
I don't,
I definitely see people as people at face value.
And I think that,
you know,
what you contribute and what you do is incredibly meaningful and important.
But,
uh,
at the end of the day,
we are all people and I think that it's tough for me to try to elevate someone
else.
And in the same regard,
when I see videos that autoplay on Facebook of Syrian refugees getting beaten on
the Macedonian border by officers with clubs,
um,
I would say that I have what,
whatever,
whatever that feeling of empathy would be for a movie star.
I shared that with them where I look at these people and I'm like,
no,
I see Kanye West.
And I'm like,
okay,
he's a person just like me.
And I see someone holding a baby getting beaten with a club.
Well,
it's pouring rain out and I say,
that person's just like me.
And it's very hard for me to,
to think of a human being as someone,
as someone other than,
than an equal.
Right.
And I realize I kind of walked over my own question or probably walked over your
answer to the,
when you feel demotivated or that you don't want to make a video,
what do you do?
It?
Is it that the,
is it that you're regimented seven day week schedule just doesn't allow the
space for that self doubt or,
oh,
no.
You know,
I didn't answer the question either.
I Digress and dumping.
But uh,
no.
So it's very real.
And Waking Up to edit.
I never want to do it.
And like yesterday I just said it was Sunday morning,
I was like,
I'm not going to do it.
And I didn't,
I didn't get my post up until one in the afternoon.
Um,
and there's a total mutiny on,
on,
on uh,
Twitter by my,
my viewers.
But uh,
I don't want to do it,
but the truth is like I can only equate it to climbing a mountain.
I've climbed some really big mountains before and when you're,
the closest to the peak is when you want to give up the most.
But the return that is standing at the summit is such a victory that the minute
you're up there,
you just want to do it again and you've forgotten about the pain.
So the hate that is the battle of the edit and the upload and the bullshit and
the getting it done and the technical problems that are outside of your control
and the camera not recording audio.
And like every other hurdle that comes between you and uploading,
all of that is absorbed.
All that is erase the moment you click upload and it's replaced with this like
sensation of adrenaline and wonderment and achievement and accomplishment that
is having made something that I now get to share.
Um,
and that was true when I was making a birthday video that help a hundred people
in a room got to see that was true when I was making videos of my son when he
was a baby and I'd share them with my family.
And that's certainly true at my daily uploads on youtube that go out to,
you know,
a million people day.
And
you,
you seem to be very contrarian.
I don't know if you've always been that way.
Uh,
but you're also very well spoken.
So you dropped out of high school.
How do you explain that?
How did you sort of develop that ability?
Um,
and it's not to say that somebody drops out of high school,
it can't be well spoken,
but it's,
it's,
uh,
I,
I'm very impressed with how well spoken you are.
So I'd just be curious to know why you think or how you develop that.
No,
I dunno,
maybe reading a lot or I was trying to surround myself with people that are
smarter than than I am.
Um,
I mean,
I can remember when I,
when I got my first real job,
when I,
at the time girlfriend was pregnant with my first kid and I was 16 years old and
I was in the back of a kitten and everybody just sort of thought that I was an
idiot probably because of my age and the fact that I was kind of a dope and I
probably talk like an idiot then as a 10th grade high school dropout who's only
previous work he experienced as selling dime bags in the parking lot of high
school.
Um,
the lack of respect and what that felt like.
And then I really remember,
you know,
again,
16 years old in the kitchen of a,
of a really dumpy seafood restaurant getting paid $8 an hour.
I really remember what would happen when I acted differently around these,
these guys that I worked in,
the hits it with how they would treat me differently and every day became this
sort of social study for me,
this social experiment we're in,
how would they respond to me acting a certain way?
And I remember like when they would pick on me instead of me trying to come up
with quippy come back to them,
I would just look them in the eye and not say anything.
And then the picking on me stopped immediately.
Um,
and I guess like that little experiment right there was something that had a
huge impact on me because you know,
the more considered I am,
when I say things more,
I think before I speak and things like that,
I think the more people respond in the way that I would hope people respond.
And the more I feel like I'm doing a good job of communicating whatever it is
that I'm trying to,
to say whatever information that isn't,
I'm trying to disseminate.
Um,
the more satisfying it is for me.
It feels great to be understood.
Um,
so I just,
I do whatever I can that best services that,
um,
as far as the educational part or being out,
uh,
an autodidact.
Yeah.
I,
the big fan of reading and a big fan of,
of World War Two and we say like,
I got all my business,
my understanding of business and how business and life works from studying the
Second World War.
Any particular books or documentaries or resources on World War II that you,
that you're a big fan of?
Oh yeah.
And I probably,
my favorite,
or at least my second favorite book in the world,
it's a textbook and it's called the Second World War by John Keegan.
Um,
and it's literally just like 1200 pages at size six fought about the second
world war.
And I remember like getting in trouble,
filling up to work tired because I'd be up all night long reading this textbook
about World War II.
So riveting to me.
Um,
I read it cover to cover probably three times and I remember reading in The New
York Times that John Keegan passed away and he goes,
you know,
late 2000,
maybe 2008,
2009 from the Gut and being deeply sad that this military lecturer,
this professor from England had died because I felt so close to him because I
read this book.
There was nothing more than an academic's perspective on the Second World War.
It was not a firsthand experience.
There's no emotion in this book.
It's pure military strategy.
And I remember deeply being emotionally affected by the fact that this guy had
had died,
but that's one book in particular that,
that really affected me.
How were you introduced to that book or how did you find it?
I have no idea.
Uh,
I mean,
I can tell you actually,
I was at a dinner party with a girl.
I had a crush on whose mother was a columnist in the New York Times and uh,
they were talking about World War II and one of them said,
what year did World War II started or something like that.
And I remember thinking in my head,
what year did World War II start?
And I literally couldn't tell you,
forget about the decade,
I couldn't tell you what part of the century it took place in.
And I remember in that moment feeling like an idiot.
The same way I felt like an idiot in the kitchen when I got picked on.
And the next day I just went to Barnes and noble cause there no Amazon then and
like found whatever looked like the most down the line,
like straight forward book on the Second World War.
So I could make sure that the next time I was in a conversation when World War
Two came up,
I'd be much more versed in it.
Amazing.
And you,
you said second favorite book.
What is,
what is the other book that was in your mind?
Um,
the autobiography of Malcolm X.
I have read that book more times than I can count.
Uh,
I cried at the end of that book.
I don't know why.
I guess I was surprised that Malcolm x was killed even though he'd been dead for
40 years,
and I knew that he had been shot.
Um,
that book resonates me in such a way.
He just like,
he was a bad kid.
He was a troublemaker.
He's arrested,
he's thrown in jail as a dropout in a thug.
And I say this like with some hesitation because that means an absolute hero
who,
who really changed the world for the better and for so many people.
Um,
so I don't compare myself to him in any capacity,
but certainly when I read that book for the first time,
I saw so many parallels between his struggles,
uh,
again,
in a universal way,
in the struggles that I had.
And he know he was a troublemaker.
He wasn't selling dime bags.
He was doing real crime with guns and robbing people.
Um,
and he went to jail.
Uh,
and you know,
he taught himself,
educated himself while in prison to the degree that he developed an astigmatism
and his eye from reading in like the super dim prison light and he went into
prison,
the,
you know,
the degenerate thug that he was,
and he came out of prison.
I think one of the greatest communicators of the 20th century.
I'm in someone who's,
whose ideas and the profundity behind the way he was able to share those ideas,
affected the world and affected the civil rights movement in such a way that we
still feel the impact of it today.
Um,
he's just such a hero in that book is written so in such a brilliant way that's
so relatable even today that I,
I can't think of another piece of,
of,
uh,
of writing that's impacted me the way that movie that book has.
When was,
he sucked,
not the movie,
the book.
What book have you gifted most to other people?
Is it one of these two or is or doesn't know the book that gifted the most to
people that there's a real trouble with gifting books,
which is that if you're gifting someone a book,
it means you think that they're going to actually read it.
Um,
and I would say more often than not,
most books that are gifted say more are more gesture by the person who gifted
them to you,
then they are you receiving them.
Like most people who gift the kind of books that I received,
they just want to feel special and be able to say,
I gave you that book.
Um,
that's a little cynicism for you.
But no,
the book I've gifted the most is a book called,
it's not how good you are.
It's how good you want to be.
I think that's the name of the Doc.
I'm going to look it up right now.
But what it is,
it's written by an ad man,
and it's about sort of the art of advertising.
That's great title.
I mean,
uh,
even if that's not the right title,
I liked the sound of it.
The reason why I get that book is because you can read it in like 40 minutes
each page.
It's like 20 words on it and each one of them captures like these really big
lofty ideas.
Here it is.
It's not how good it's how good you want to be by Paul Arden.
And each book has like huge hundred and 50 font text where it says one sentence,
but each one like really punches you in the stomach and a really big way.
Um,
and I think this book has the ability,
and it was written by an Admin,
but I think it's really,
it's just about creativity in general.
It had a breakthrough,
um,
in a way that really affects you.
I think that there is a passage in there where he talks about how when hiring
and when being,
when hiring always see someone who's been fired or who has quit their previous
job as a virtue.
And like,
it's a bunch of little items like that.
And I don't know,
I just think it's a magnificent book that you can sit down and we'll shake
anybody up who reads it?
I'll check it out.
I'm in the shakeup phase at the moment.
Uh,
he,
I'm going to ask just a couple of rapid fire questions.
They don't need to be rapid fire answers,
but I'll throw just a,
uh,
a bunch of questions at you.
Uh,
what $100 or less purchase has most positively impacted your life in the last
six to 12 months or whatever comes to mind?
Oh,
$100 or less purchase.
That's a really,
really challenging answer.
Our question to answer.
MMM.
Not extremely expensive.
No,
I understand.
Yeah.
Um,
so it's not that recent,
but it is something that I say to young people want to get into film making.
But the movie that I shot,
the film,
the camera that I shot,
the bike lanes movie on costs $150,
uh,
and you started this interview out by,
by asking about that movie and I think that speaks to just how impactful that
movie was.
And that movie was shot and $150 camera from Walmart and that movie was edited
in Imovie,
which is free software.
So I think that when I look back at like where it's really big impacts been when
it comes to making a little investment that that movie and that that $150
investment and the impact that it had on my life and my career is something that
I often point to as like,
don't blame it on the gear.
Don't believe it on a lack of resources because it's never the resources that
determine your success.
It's,
it's how you use what you have.
And is there any entry level camera that you might suggest to people now who are
looking for an equivalent and just getting started?
Or is the phone good enough?
I mean,
I think the phones now are great.
They're way better than good enough.
But if you look at a lot of the big bloggers like logging was,
was,
uh,
was invented by people just using the webcams on their computers.
Um,
so I really just don't think the quality matters.
I think cell phones now are incredible.
If you want to get something bigger than that,
you go to the store and you buy whatever the whatever the cheapest canon point
and shoot cameras at all as a high def video record button.
They get stereo sound,
they've got zoom.
It's more than what you need to tell a great story.
It's never the hardware,
it's only how you use it.
And speaking of loggers,
so I'm not familiar with the world of loggers outside of your own who are a few
bloggers,
maybe they have different styles that people could check out just to get a feel
for how people are going about doing this.
Uh,
sure.
I mean,
so there's one guy who's a good friend of mine,
his name is Ben Brown,
spelled as you'd imagine.
And Ben is,
uh,
Ben's a guy who,
he's a really honest,
Frank Guy and I think what Ben does in blogging,
he's a daily Vlogger.
That's,
so his vlogs are very much so by definition,
just the diarrhea his life.
Um,
but I think what Ben does better than anyone is he really is himself on camera.
So what you're seeing on cameras,
who he is in real life and what the impact of that is in aggregate is that after
you spend day in and day out watching his 10 minute blogs,
if your day is he becomes a friend,
he becomes a friend by proxy and he lives in somewhat adventurous life.
He's got a beautiful girlfriend in Cape Town,
South Africa where he spends the majority of his time,
even though he's from England and he travels a lot for work.
His work is logging.
Um,
so you sort of,
you span this guy's life along with him and the idea that you,
you,
you feel like you become friends with him.
Um,
so I think he really captures what is the,
the romanticism behind blogging behind sharing your life in a,
in a daily capacity.
A video.
Got It.
Any,
uh,
anyone else come to mind just so people can look at a few different options?
Sure.
There's a guy named fun for Louie,
um,
fun,
fun for fund four,
l o U I s Louie Louie is,
is very similar to Ben and Louis is like a godfather of logging.
And doing it for like four years.
He's someone who is like six foot,
four long dreadlocks and just rejected the grind and he wanted to live a life of
adventure.
And he literally is traveling 365 days a year.
And he bankrolls it all by sharing those experiences that he,
he does via his camera and be a youtube.
He doesn't drink,
he doesn't do drugs,
he doesn't have a girlfriend.
He's just an honest guy on sort of a,
a journey to,
to define himself.
Um,
and I find his blogs to be very humble and honest and um,
they capture who he is and he shares that in a way that I think he's extremely
relatable.
What,
what are the most common misconceptions about you or your work would you say?
God,
that's tough and it's tough.
Only because I paid such little attention to the negative people and the people
that are,
are wasting their time criticizing.
Um,
what,
what did they call that about Steve Jobs is
the reality.
Um,
so what are the biggest misconceptions?
you know,
people think I'm really rich and I think that's a kind of a frustrating
misconception.
And the reason why it's frustrating isn't because I don't have a wonderful,
absolutely privileged life,
which I do.
Um,
it's frustrating because of how many times in life I've said no huge paychecks
because they didn't align with who I am as a person.
Um,
you know,
I said no to a hundred thousand dollar job today on Youtube because of what they
wanted me to do and what they wanted me to say.
I just passed on it.
And that's been the case from when I was really,
really broke.
Uh,
if it wasn't something that I thought I could get behind that I believed in,
I just said no.
Um,
and I think that if,
if money were my focus,
I would have found a home in advertising done very well there and never looked
back.
But instead of I've always stayed true to what really matters to me.
Um,
this sharing ideas and sharing perspectives and I've done that with tremendous
financial risk,
um,
that that has cost me,
probably prevented me from being this rich guy that,
that people think that I am.
How,
how do you decide what to say no to?
So for instance,
if,
if you're comfortable talking about it and I ask because I'm constantly trying
to get better at saying no.
And you mentioned Steve Jobs and he was a,
he's famously quoted for a lot of things,
but one of them was,
you know,
innovation is saying no to a thousand things,
uh,
or being successful saying no to a thousand things and sort of always striving
for that simplicity.
What did the company,
what made you uncomfortable that led to the know?
Um,
or you could speak more generally if you want to,
but I'm trying to get better at this myself and I'm always looking for playbooks
or rules that other people use.
Uh,
or I was terrified,
absolutely terrified to say no for so long.
And it's because it was such a novel idea,
this,
this idea that someone was willing to pay me to pick up a camera,
something that I had not just done for free,
but something that I had like spent every,
every last cent of my life to be able to do and now people are willing to pay me
and then willing to pay me a shit load of money.
And then I had to say no.
So it's something that was really scary for me to do.
Um,
but I would say that transition happened a couple of years ago.
Uh,
and the more I said no,
the more it made me feel better.
And,
uh,
I,
I don't know what the science to it is,
but I can tell you that when I launched,
I launched,
but when I got the first little bit of financing for my technology company and
went from being an idea to something more tangible,
um,
I just immediately said no to everything.
And that's pretty much where I lie right now is everything is given one filter
and that one filter is,
is this good for me and my tech company?
And if the answer is no,
it's a,
it's a pass at at the answer is that yes it gets in an examination.
And uh,
and I definitely want to talk about beam for people who also want to sort of
develop this ability to say no.
There's a commencement speech by Neil Gaiman called make good art,
which I just find fantastic,
but he has some really good metaphors for this as well.
Um,
and I'm going to come back to beam in just a second,
but what,
uh,
what do you believe that other people think is insane
or what is a belief that you have that other people think many people think is
crazy?
Uh,
it's funny cause to the listeners out there,
I'm talking to you right now,
not Tim,
but Tim sent me all these questions saying,
if you want to rehearse for this so you have the answers.
And I came back with an emphatic,
I don't like to know the questions ahead of time because then they're rehearsed.
And now I'm finding myself with these really challenging lessons,
grasping,
grasping to come up with an answer.
That's true.
Um,
okay.
What do I believe that that's crazy.
Um,
or that other people think is crazy,
but you might not.
And this is it.
This is a common interview question and this is a paraphrase that Peter Teal
cofounder or former CEO of paypal and a first money into Facebook that he uses a
lot.
Um,
this is,
um,
something you believe that's controversial or that other people think.
I think they talk about this in the first chapter of zero to one.
I'm sure it comes up.
Uh,
I,
you know,
I believe in the religion of work and working hard.
And I think that,
uh,
I think that that's something that people resist and people resist the notion of
in the more I find myself sort of preaching the values and the virtues of that,
the more resistant are,
um,
but I just believe that anything can be achieved through hard work.
Uh,
and it's hard.
It's hard to say.
As I,
as I'm hearing myself say that it sounds like something that,
you know,
some,
some dipshit guy who's found successful say,
but I really like the truth is,
the harder I work is the harder I work,
the more successful I am.
And,
and moreover,
you realize that like,
you will never,
you'll never be the best looking person in the room.
You'll never be the smartest person in the room.
You'll never be the most educated,
the best well verse you'll,
you'll never be,
you can never compete on those levels.
You'll never be the most edgy.
You'll never be able to compete on those levels.
But what you can always compete on.
The true like egalitarian aspect of success is hard work.
You can always work harder than the next guy and if you're willing to work
harder than the next guy,
you will succeed because most people,
like I always say when when someone's like,
yeah,
but I'm not going to dedicate,
I'm not going to commit to working like that.
I'm not waking up.
I'm not,
how did he sleep?
A couple of,
I'm not going to do,
I'm not.
The second I hear someone say that,
I think to myself,
great,
that is one less person I have to climb over on my way to the top because I know
what hard work can yield and I know just how,
just how meaningful,
hard working day.
There's a one of my,
I,
it's,
I don't know why I'm so embarrassed to admit this,
but one of my favorite semi sort of a documentary,
but it's more of a historical reenactment film that I've seen is called miracle
and it's a Disney movie with Kurt Russell about this just incredible story of
the US hockey team and the Olympics at Lake placid.
Going against the,
the Soviets are considered unbeatable.
But in one of the training sessions,
he says,
you know,
they're just bickering amongst themselves and,
and uh,
and looking at hot chicks in the stands instead of taking the game seriously.
And he's like,
oh,
well,
I know you guys think you have a lot of talent,
but talent,
you don't have enough talent to make it in this particular game,
but I can promise you that we'll outwork every other team that,
that,
that's going to play us in the Olympics.
Um,
so yeah,
I,
I do think there's a lot,
a lot to pull from that.
The
tech companies.
So tell me a little,
tell me and the listeners about beam,
but related to that,
I mean,
you have a,
you have an amazing life.
You've,
you've created an amazing life for yourself through experimentation and hard
work.
Um,
have been a popular director.
You have Sundance,
Hbo,
et Cetera.
You can make a lot of money.
Some youtubers,
I'm not going to say you,
but you tubers can make a,
you know,
five,
six figures for product placement on Youtube.
So why on earth start a tech company and a,
and then what,
what is the tech company?
Uh,
you know,
it's,
it was at the height.
It was at the peak of my career that I actually pivoted to starting this tech
company.
The peak of that career
is one of doing branded content deals on my youtube channel.
And Yeah,
those deals were six figures in seven figure deals.
Huge,
huge,
huge deals.
And in starting my company,
my technology coming actually shut down my production company that was doing
those tremendous deals.
So a part of that rejection around me being rich is because of that is because
I,
I shut down,
I killed the,
uh,
I killed the golden goose.
Yeah.
I killed,
I killed the cow that I had been milking for years to do this because that's how
much I believe in this.
Um,
but what started the tech company was this,
I was,
I was doing advertising work for youtube from a youtube channel and it was
fantastically successful as a tremendously proud of it,
all of that.
Um,
but I really felt like I had exhausted it.
I had reached a plateau where people,
uh,
I was doing similar work and even though it was good and people love that,
I didn't feel like it was moving me forward in any way.
And it was around that time that I was invited to,
uh,
to MIT,
Massachusetts Institute of Technology and I was invited there via the Sundance
Institute and a grant from the Rockefeller Foundation and they invited me to
live on campus and work out of the media lab for six months.
And I remember thinking about that.
My initial gut response was like,
leave my company for six months.
How much is that going to possibly cost me?
Like I can't afford to do?
That's crazy.
Say No to all this money.
I've never said no to anything in my life.
Um,
and the more I thought about the more I was like,
you know what?
I can probably afford to do this.
I can probably afford to live off my savings for six months.
I'll be dead broke at the end of it.
But this is an opportunity unlike anything else.
And I just in the end said,
fuck it.
And I went for it and I lived on campus and I never went to college number,
went to high school,
never went to college.
And I just went there with a wide open mind and I had wanted Janda.
And that agenda was when I leave here,
I want to make sure I have an understanding.
I'm doing something that I've,
I've,
I've never done before.
I'm doing something that is not currently on the books because I don't get it.
And while at Mit I learned one thing,
one very meaningful,
one very powerful thing.
That one thing was that with technology,
almost anything is achievable.
Um,
and therefore I,
I took that understanding when I came back to New York after my,
my tenure there was over to my semester,
there was over,
my fellowship was complete.
I came back to New York and I came back to New York and I wanted to solve a
problem.
Um,
I wanted to solve a problem that I identified years ago,
but I didn't think was solvable.
And I wanted to take this new understanding that I could solve big problems with
technology.
And I wanted to realize that.
And that was the prelude to me starting a technology company.
And,
and can you explain the premise of a,
of beam tell people where they can check it out.
But,
uh,
also the,
how it works.
I mean the basic,
the basic
conceit,
bind it.
Yeah,
sure.
So that problem,
that problem that I really wanted to solve was one that my life has been so
impacted in such a meaningful way by my ability to share my ideas and my
perspective.
Um,
but I have a unique,
unfair competitive advantage when it comes to sharing ideas and perspectives,
which is that I know how to make movies.
I have this creative expression so I can fear my perspective because of that.
Um,
Larry King,
I had a CNN talk show,
he shares perspective because of that.
And is there a way to,
with technology make it so you can actually share perspectives and share ideas
without having to create something?
Can you bifurcate this idea of creation from this idea of sharing?
Um,
and that was a problem that I wanted to solve.
And that to unpack that a little bit,
even something like a,
a a youtube at first requires you to make a video and then you have to upload a
video.
There's an act of creation in there.
When you think of something like Instagram,
like delivery,
you have to come up with that clever tweet.
Um,
snapchat,
you have to shoot something,
you review it,
you edit it,
you see what it looks like,
you add some filters to it,
you draw on the screen and then you get to share what would it look like if you
were to remove the entire process?
All of the mechanics of creation.
And that's what beam is.
That's how beam work.
So literally how being works.
And it's B e m e beam.
How it works is you covered the proximity sensor on your,
on your cell phone.
In the proximity sensors is tiny black dot.
That's right above the speaker hole at the top of your phone.
Um,
and when you covered that sensor automatically starts recording a video clip and
the minute that clip is done,
which is four seconds later,
it's immediately posted to your feet.
Um,
so what that looks like in practice is when you see something of interest,
when there's something you want to share,
an idea perspective,
I don't know,
it's not a cute puppy.
Anything you want to share,
you just hold your phone to your chest or you put your son over the proximity
sensor,
the screen goes black,
it captures,
it vibrates when it's done,
and then you put the phone back in your pocket and you just shared something
using the most media rich content that's ever existed,
which is,
which is video would sound and you've done it without ever having to create that
ever having to take in front that burden.
That is a creative expression.
Very cool.
Yeah.
I've uh,
I've been watching it with,
with great interest and playing around with it,
so I encourage people to check it out.
I know we're coming up on time for both of us.
So I want to just ask a couple more questions and then,
uh,
absolutely gonna ask you to share where people can come check out a number of
things related to your work.
What are,
uh,
some underrated,
the most underrated documentaries or movies in your mind?
Just a fee.
They could just be a few films that people might check out that perhaps they
haven't come across because they haven't been fully appreciated.
Um,
okay.
So my favorite movie is probably the life and death of Colonel Blimp,
which is a movie.
It's a British movie was made,
uh,
there was made during World War Two and it's my favorite movie period.
It's a movie that Wes Anderson really studied and you can see a lot of his style
in that movie.
Um,
for example,
like the opening title sequence,
all of the credits are employed into gigantic blanket and the shots are just
have that blank.
And this a movie that was made in 1940,
I think 1941.
Um,
and that movie to me is like,
that's my favorite movie.
See captures everything I love about filmmaking.
Um,
but it also had to be made at a time when the country is priority,
was saving themselves from destruction and death and instead,
you know,
like that's the priority.
And instead,
like at that same time,
they decided to make a movie and like that is such a novel,
such a wild idea.
Um,
and they had no resources and when they needed big wide establishing shots,
I just filmed a painting because they couldn't fly a balloon or a airplane to
take the shot because it was,
it was during the war.
Um,
so that's my favorite movie.
Other movies,
like my favorite doc is probably if they were documentary is probably little
dieter needs to fly,
which is a movie from,
from Verner Herzog from 1997.
How do you spell d?
I.
E.
D.
R,
I guess D.
I t.
E r and little little dieter needs to fly is about,
uh,
it's about,
Vietnam,
uh,
u s Vietnam fighter pilot.
He gets shot down his very first mission and he's trapped as a pow for a number
of years.
And the movie was actually made as a fictional narrative.
Uh,
or nonsexual narrative are called rescue dawn with Christian Bale a couple of
years ago.
But skip the Christian Bale and just watched the documentary.
That movie will bring you to your knees and it shows you like that's one of
those movies at anytime you're having a bad day or you think you've got it hard,
you watch that movie and you understand what it means to like to survive.
Um,
you know,
it's a story of a Guy Oh eight,
eight maggots for four years and finally escaped and that best friend killed and
you know,
much of the interviews that were done were with him when he was living in,
I think in Portland,
Oregon or something like that.
And then theater takes you into his basement and underground.
He has like hundreds of pounds of sugar and flour and oats in the u s in the 90s
because he's so scared of being hungry again that he wanted to make sure no
matter what,
he'll never be hungry again for the rest of his life.
And it's just like,
it captures humanity in such a visceral,
such a real way.
And it's a work of nonfiction.
So it's really,
that's a movie that,
that that's,
that's,
that's moved me.
Sounds like a great perspective adjuster.
Uh,
if you could have one billboard anywhere,
what would you put on it and where would you put it?
Uh,
can,
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
I'd probably,
I'd want to,
I'd love to have a billboard,
someone that just reminds people to be nice.
Um,
uh,
where I've put it is wherever the most people would possibly see it.
But I think that we in,
I don't know that communication,
uh,
essay do I think the communication,
social networks,
he internet has made this better.
It's,
it's going in the right direction.
And I think people are so quick to be judgmental and be negative.
And the truth is like,
you give other people the benefit of the doubt and you,
you have a positive approach to everything in life that you end up being happier
and it's better for them.
It's like that,
that absolutely quantifiable mathematical equation,
which is that it,
what's best for you and me is better for me than just what's better for me.
Does that make sense?
I'll say it again.
Sorry.
That benefits Tim and KC is better than for Casey than just something that
benefits Casey and I think positivity and being nice as a big part of that.
It's something that's often overlooked.
Agreed.
What,
uh,
what advice would you give your 20 year old self?
20 year old?
Yeah.
Or,
or 25,
whichever you okay.
I mean I would say about 15 year olds down south,
but um,
yeah,
you can answer that one.
Uh,
it would be don't listen to anyone.
Um,
don't listen to anyone.
I,
I have a rule which is always listened to everyone and then reject everything
you don't like.
Um,
but the truth is like so many people love Cheley knowledge and it has such an
impact on people and affects them in such a way.
And the truth is no one knows anything.
And life is this malleable mushy piece of clay that's only up to you to shape.
And when you look too much to other people to help you shape that piece of clay,
that is your life.
You end up with a,
with a compromised life.
Stocks is something that's not your own.
How do you end up feeling overwhelmed by the paradox of choice in a situation
like that?
Um,
if you adopt that philosophy,
and I'm not,
I mean I tend to agree a lot of the time,
but I also at points feel like I have too much optionality.
Um,
and it makes it very difficult to navigate and there's a lot of self doubt and
maybe that's just my own neuroses that need a addressing.
But
how do you,
how do you find direction in all of those options and all that freedom?
No,
that's a really,
that's a,
that's $1 billion question.
And I think if you could answer that,
I don't have an answer for that.
I can tell you that.
Um,
I can tell you that my wife is someone who,
I actually agree with me if you're going to say this,
but she's just someone who's crippled by indecision.
She's told me twice in front of her and her lack of ability just to zero and
one,
it's,
it affects her in a tremendously negative way.
And I tend to be very George Bush,
the second George Bush about this.
Um,
I'm not a tremendous fan of George Bush at all.
Right.
But that man made mostly bad decisions,
but he made decisions and um,
I really
believe I need to come up with a better person.
But I really believe like you make a decision and you move on that decision and
it's better to later in life figured out that that was the wrong decision than
it is to sit around and have never had made a decision in the first place.
And that's a really scary thing to do.
But the truth is like,
I'm only 35 years old,
but I'm also 35 years old and I would,
whatever it is,
20 years in it as an adult now,
which is just about enough time to look back and start to examine,
examine things.
And I,
I think that having always opted to trust my instinct because my instincts were
there to keep me alive,
to trust me and sinks in to move on them has only benefited me despite myriad
failures along the way.
Yeah,
I can,
I can see how the World War II reading probably influenced,
uh,
without what I agree with is the ability to make decisions with incomplete
information.
Uh,
very good.
A very good advice.
Last question before we wrap up.
Do you have any ask or request for my audience,
anything that you would ask them to do or suggest that they do?
Uh,
no.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's wonderful having an audience to speak to.
Um,
and something that I always tried to tell anyone that will listen even though I
had just started her dating myself by saying never listened to anyone.
But it's just that idea of being nice.
Um,
when you share positivity out there,
like he comes back and such a big way and that's sets a lame like TV evangelists
thing to say.
But the truth is like that is so meaningful.
It is so cheap.
It is so inexpensive.
It is so easy to be cynical,
to be negative,
to be someone who brings other people down and brings yourself down is really
easy to do.
Being Nice,
being positive is really hard work,
but you feel so much better.
At the end of the day.
It's just like exercise.
You don't want to get out there and do your run.
You don't want to go to the gym.
But when you do it,
you feel so much better.
Switch.
Glad you switched better off that you did it.
And at the end of the day,
at the end of life,
at the end of the year,
the aggregate of having done that,
having put in the work to be a more positive person,
um,
that's really tremendous.
And I know there are two kids now,
so I say all this in their shadows and um,
the older I get,
the more I really believe in that and I work hard to achieve that every minute
of every day.
What do you,
people have asked me this,
so I'm going to ask you what,
what do you,
what have you been listening to most when you run recently?
The problem with me as a mom,
I'm not much of a loyalist and it comes to music.
I hate that answer.
I love everything.
But I love everything.
I'm an old friend of mine.
His name's Johnny.
Uh,
Johnny famous as his name on,
on Spotify.
And that's no age.
J.
O.
N n y famous Johnny famous.
I just listened to his playlist.
He was like this incredible deejay who's deejayed parties with me.
All kinds of fun stuff.
But I just go to him and I'll let Johnny what you listening to and Spotify
enables that and I just listened to his playlist.
So it's not a super sexy answer,
but it's true.
No,
it's specific.
It's perfect.
All right.
I,
this has been so much fun.
Uh,
I know we've,
we've tried to connect over the past weeks and months and it's,
it's,
it's finally here in front of us.
Where can people find you on the Internet?
Where can they check out you and your work and maybe maybe give them a video or
two to start with a also.
Yeah,
I mean,
everything I've ever done is on youtube.
If you just type my name into Google,
you'll find it.
Uh,
if I had to say start somewhere,
watch that movie,
make it count.
Cause we just spend some time talking about it.
Um,
and then another movie that I like to point to is I'm moving,
I work really hard on that is kind of under,
under watched on Youtube,
but it's,
it's called draw my life and basically it's,
it is like my autobiography that I made via little drawings that a friend of
mine did.
And it's something I worked super hard on it.
It's like a 12 minute summation of everything I've done from birth until age 30
or so.
And it's something I'm really,
really proud of.
That little movie.
Uh,
and then your audience to download beam be Emmy.
It's on the APP store now.
We'll have it on android probably November or working really hard to get it
there.
But beam is a really,
really exciting,
really it's a burgeoning community that's growing every day.
And um,
I don't know the more people that are a part of being more exciting.
I'm so awesome.
Well,
Casey,
thank you so much for taking the time and everybody listening for show notes
links to everything that we mentioned in this conversation.
You can just go to four hour workweek.com all spelled out and click on podcasts
that also has all past episodes and a Casey,
this is great.
Hopefully we can hang out when we're in the same city and uh,
best of luck with everything.
Thanks for taking the time.
Of course.
Is it in?
Fantastic.
Take care of 10.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Fridays,
a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab,
it uses it to tell the company story and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and a fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
demio.com forward slash business,
that's v I n e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25%
off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash business promo code.
Tim,
and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Okay?
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.